we big-time 50,000 views huh Terron
Forte the eighth grader love your mother
young fellah odds of getting into the
NBA talent and hard work on enough you
also need someone in your corner who
knows a system and add a play it for you
coach gains Liberty prep we're offering
you some full ride scholarship and
that's how much we believe in his
potential work just as hard off the
court as you will on it promise my
name's T which I got it they care team
he told us about the coach my starting
tonight yeah you're gonna be starting a
little man minute after never practices
workouts games want you to bury your
nose in this play look good come on tour
kick your ass
Joe is what you got
[Music]
there's only 14 years old you are now an
official prospect in the eyes of the
NCAA and handle the recruiting process
which is these agents you know gonna
juice you we have got to figure out how
to use them to get out with him you
realize how involved you how much did
you hear I heard everything
plate the college you know play for the
NBA we play for the break
Oh things rigged against the people it
should be helping the most he's the
reason this all exists and he can't be
paid $1 he's got to keep winning work
all right
what if you don't make it do with my
player rough
if your son is the player I believe he
is he's gonna be making millions of
dollars while he's still a teenager
[Music]
you